désolé de vous déranger vous avez besoin
qu'on vous aide il faut que je me sorte
d'une relation toxique horrible
si tu commences par nous expliquer ce
qui t'amène
mon patron
particulier t'arrive pas à te le sortir
de la tête non
tu as l'impression qu'il pourrait
détruire simplement claquant des doigts
sans même les claquer
ok ah oui ça on connaît bien oui
apporte-moi des victimes innocentes je
veux une tablée de bonne sœur un quart
de cheerleaders
et moi je voudrais une vie normale
mais le monde moderne est dangereux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci vous m'avez sauvé la vie est-ce
que je vous ai vu éclater un type d'un
seul coup de plateau tout est dans le
poignet
je vais vous expliquer mon patron m'a
donné des pouvoirs
en échange je satisfais à ses besoins je
m'occupe de lui je le nourris vous lui
amener des gens à manger
[Musique]
vous êtes le mec qui livre la bouffe que
commande le méchant mais que se
passera-t-il si tu arrêtes de penser à
ses besoins et pourra pas retrouver sa
pleine puissance oui c'est ça il pourra
pas retrouver sa pleine puissance waouh
c'est trop bizarre comme façon de le
dire mais oui c'est ça
bonsoir vous venez pour la réunion je
vous en prie entraînant
certains m'appellent le prince des
ténèbres d'autres le seigneur de la mort
mais pour beaucoup je suis
Dracula ok manifestement ce n'est pas
qu'une simple question de narcissisme